let's move out to Syria because it sort
of been pushed away now that Iran has
taken over the sort of bigger world
stage picture at the moment January
actually marked the most amount of
people killed in Syria in the entire
conflict 6,000 people that brings the
total up to a hundred and thirty-six
thousand people just crazy completely
crazy there's about two million people
displaced in Syria already uh and what I
wanted to talk about was that so John
Kerry was our secretary state obviously
he was quoted by Lindsey Graham Senator
Lindsey Graham saying bless you saying
bless you uh we we are at a point now
when we're going to have to change our
strategy talking about Syria then the
State Department immediately backtracked
on that and said that that's not true
that everything's okay not look we John
Kerry was call this guy Hitler we almost
went to war then they sort of said they
were getting rid of the chemical weapons
it looks like maybe five percent or out
the killing is still going on so I don't
want to get into all the minutiae of
Syria because it's it's a lot of stuff
but what this was making can anyone
trust anything that America is doing any
more like you can we trust that either
Kerry is making the right decisions or
even that we even here remotely anything
close to it wasn't it a kind of a
he-said she-said thing there was what
McCain it's what McCain and Lindsey
rammers said they heard versus a woman
say no I was in the room and this is
what was said she's words were also
manipulated so they took certain aspects
of what he said in twisted was to what
they wanted no here they report let me
ask you one thing what is the big deal
with Kerry saying what we're doing isn't
working we've been working on stuff with
Syria since but they were established as
a nation to think in 1947 since 1947
we've helped stage coos in their country
we've actually WikiLeaks has shown that
we've sent them money we've sent money
to their anti you know government
propaganda TV news network we've sent
them money we've sent them equipment
we've sent everything not Syria the
government but we've sent the rebels
basically money and a clean and
everything about their own country we're
still doing it there's proof through
WikiLeaks so if Kerry was like hmm you
know what this has been going on for I
don't know sixties years maybe we need
to change our strategy right gia BFD
right well that's order that sort of my
point is whether fruit intact
yeah freakin deal if somebody in America
is finally going to actually admit that
maybe we need to change strategy maybe
we need to stop playing World Police
maybe we need to stop being involved in
everything so much to try to control i
get that there next to israel i get that
they have interested in Russia I
understand we're trying to protect
ourselves through this but maybe they
just like back off and maybe we need to
let people like John Kerry do their
supposed to do which is assess the
situation and give their honest opinion
unless someone like done carry to either
say yes we're on the right track or no
we need to you know really I think we're
so I'm on board what you're saying there
but to me it's like whether what John
Kerry said behind closed doors was
correctly quoted by a Lindsey Graham or
whether it was incorrectly quoted by
Lindsey Graham I feel like we don't
trust our politicians and we don't trust
our media and we don't trust the State
Department so when I read this article I
was like I don't believe any of any and
I think that's them as long as they say
what we want them to say ah yes the
great that's the rub yeah I don't trust
them either right I didn't understand
exactly what you're saying I feel like I
could imagine that certain Republican
would want to manipulate what John Kerry
said it's in order to especially to take
down the position Hillary Clinton tus
this isn't really just about John Kerry
this is that the Democrats and how
they're handling fall in foreign policy
this is about saying that John Kerry was
in the right place at Hillary Clinton
didn't do her job as it always will come
down to her in the fear of her winning
the election in 2016 yeah then you have
the media wantons to sensationalize a
story which is a small he said she said
which should have been on page god knows
what but instead they're gonna make it a
big thing because it's like the soap
opera of government we have like Lindsey
Graham and like John McCain and
everything together Lindsey Graham and
John became harder they always geniune
and kicking it together yeah they're
very have the same opinion you know I
lose an arizona for over 10 years and
john mccain's obviously very prevalent
there and he was a reasonable man i
always really liked him and I'd I was
probably going to vote for john mccain
until he took Sarah Palin on as a
running mate and then lately it's just
I'm glad I didn't because I don't know
where this craziness right now then you
started dating lindsey graham and all
day whether [ __ ] um alright so let's
move away from the he said she says I
think we're kind of agreed we don't know
what the truth is on that so just a
little bit about Syria have we just
given them a green light to kill but I
was completely against going to war but
by not doing anything and now maybe
they're getting the chemical weapons out
and Russia's still arming Assad and
we're
the rebels and Iran's helping Assad and
it's like have we just given them a
license just kill as many hundred thirty
six thousand people is there anything
that we I don't think serious I mean I
think I think because of our 24-hour
news situation now we're more aware of
it but I don't think serious something
new I think that things like this would
be going on for a very very very long
time right but is there anything we can
do with this like they do they know that
we're not going to do they know we're
not gonna do anything so then it just in
in bolsa both sides of our mouth instead
we're saying well we support this
government actually happen we've
actually asked was of a prime minister
over there right then we've asked him to
step down I think Obama officially is
asked him president David president
Hassan I was for the prime minister
president there so you ask the president
there out loud to step down and then
kind of like passive aggressively funded
things behind their back you know funded
basically you know stuff for the rebels
on it over to rise up funded
anti-government propaganda over there so
i think my point in this in the end is
if we are going to be doing stuff like
that and understand we can't tell ever
what we're doing we have to kind of live
at military operations you get in
trouble but why can't someone using
position our government say we've been
making mistakes and maybe we should try
something new because as you said we've
been doing the same thing for this isn't
anything new it's going on for years and
years and similar things are happening
with other country or countries and
heather has forever yeah